necessary because if it's not necessary
that it's limited what's your definition
of necessary cuz you keep using it
incorrectly what's your understanding of
necessary existence well you know you
were talking about contingent things
it's the opposite of that something that
can you give us there's something that
cannot happen differently they can and
there's no information for it outside of
itself
well I suppose okay so can you can you
can you tell us how they can be a world
with no necessary existence well who
says well you said we're living in a
world of possible or you said that we
have to play that we're living in a
world of possible existences do you
agree that there could be an ability
explain that do you accept that there is
a necessary existence I would say that
yes then that's good that doesn't have
to that does not it does not have to be
there for us and necessary existence is
something which is this is the perfect
it couldn't be another way explains
everything else that's our definition of
everything else because without this
necessary couldnt be any other way
Oh Alex all contingent things depend
upon it yes give me an example of a
contingent thing anything this Cup
how is it contingent because it could
have otherwise not been in existence do
you know you're speaking to a
determinist fun yeah okay so what is the
tourism so if if you said your and your
thing sorry what the terminal yeah yes
let me ask you questions one you - later
but it will make sense go ahead if P
entails Q go he is necessary yes it's
cute necessary no it's not no no no it's
not it doesn't have to be if necessary
so look let me explain why what we're
doing here is we've said that these
dependent contingent things as you're
defining them do you accept that this
cup could have otherwise not been in
existence no so okay this that's what to
tell it isn't it well don't you believe
in the determinism yes and you said in
your you said in your speech
in your thing a universe from nothing
you said that
determinism comes from the necessary
existence right yes
forty-eight minutes in you said that one
necessarily leads from the other are in
other words determinism lease from
necessary distance yes or no you said
you said determinism leads from
necessary
since okay I think we were talking about
a different thing no no you said this
and I can show 48 minutes I said that so
no you know you said the university
knows it isn't hard being semantic point
scoring exercises it's not anything
different by what you're no problem but
you said this you said and you said you
said determinism comes from the
necessary existence what did I mean by
that I mean two days ago the guy asked
you is the universe would you agree with
Bertrand Russell that the universe just
is yeah and you replied and said yeah
the fact that Universal necessary
existence the I would agree with that in
the first instance and then he said how
would that tie in with determinism you
then said determinism follows from is
that which follows determinism follows
from the necessary existence right I try
to know what you'd remember I was taught
so I was I was the person was debating
with the local camera - yeah making the
cat he was making the case with the
contingency argument right I'm saying
that there are contingent things in the
universe and therefore he was using that
to reason that there's a god and I said
that if that were the case yes that
necessary existence the continued to man
isn't fallout from that I was making
okay so I didn't bring it does it listen
Alex I didn't say that it does we agree
with you on that point so this is the
thing you agree with us on more points
than you think you agree with us on you
believe in a necessary existence which
explains everything else necessary
existence be careful Ness you said and
necessary existence you are you
retracting it I said that the are you're
struggling the universe there's not one
unified necessary existed you said that
the universe wasn't necessarily the
universe follows a necessary causal
chain okay so they said is there you
said hold on you said the universe is a
necessary existence and then you said
determinism follows from that now I'm
saying that okay if I said that and I
meant what you think I meant by yes I
retract it but it's attracted but I
don't think that's what I think what it
is alex is that you people can go and
look at other stuff so you were very
good at making arguments against things
that used to believe it
okay so nothing's even it because okay
now it's perfect
no no it's important guys because if you
feel changing you and I have money and I
haven't yet that's the only reason why
you've changed your okay thank you